And then we've got some of the other bits of functionality.
So what we've covered so far is the various ways
that data can boil through.
But once we're working within code,
understanding things about our network environment
can become quite important.
So this isn't so much about dormancy.
This is more about when you're writing your code,
when you're writing, whether or not something is replicated,
knowing whether you're on the server,
whether you're on a client, what your current configuration
state is becomes quite important.
And that's where things like net mode come in.
So net mode, again, this is probably
more of an unreal bespoke specific end of things.
But it may have a corollary on other proprietary software
that you've worked with.
But essentially, net mode is the most airtight,
watertight way of checking what your current state is.
We've talked in previous sessions
about the idea of using with client code pragmas,
with server code pragmas.
But we've also talked about the fact that in editor,
on standalone, both of those things will be true.
So we can't always trust code that we write within those
pragmas to only be suitable for the client
or only be suitable for the server.
And so that's where net mode comes in.
Net mode can essentially have four states.
It can be standalone, dedicated server,
listen server or client.
So standalone, I think we've talked
about this configuration in our first session.
But essentially, this is running in total isolation.
So we never have to worry about a server coming in
and writing into our data.
We never have to worry about sending our data elsewhere.
This is kind of a local build of our game.
So if we have a game that is somehow
both single-player and multiplayer,
maybe that would be the situation you're in here.
You might be in standalone.
But for the most part, if you're making
a single-player game and you queried your net mode
of any of your actors,
their net mode would be standalone.
Dedicated server is the kind of opposite.
It's where nothing in the game is being played.
We already talked about the kind of role
of a dedicated server.
So this is purely when we are the server.
So we're not gonna have any local controllers.
The only players are gonna be simulated players
that are actually gonna be remote connections
that are gonna be dealt with on another PC.
So we are responsible for sending data to them,
but us ourselves, well, we are the server,
so we're the thing responsible for managing
all the authoritative state about the game.
But also, we know we're not gonna be displaying
any visuals.
We know we don't need to be displaying effects
or playing sound effects or anything like that.
Then we've got listen server.
Again, we've talked about the role
of the listen server already,
but in this context, we are both a server and a client.
So this net mode listen server
is only gonna be true for the person
who is the listen server.
Everyone else is gonna be a client.
So if I am hosting an online co-op game
and I am the host and I'm hosting the server locally,
then it's quite likely I would be a listen server then
and that means I am both a client playing
and I am a server responsible for sending
all the information of my local machine
out to other connected clients.
So that's that situation.
And then last of all, we have client,
which is kind of the opposite of dedicated server
where we're kind of expecting to be not the authority
for almost any data in the game
or most of the authoritative data about the game
is gonna be coming into us.
We're not gonna be sending a huge amount out.
It is our responsibility to send particular updates
to the server.
So things like input or state changes
that we know are only local changes.
Again, I talked about customizations
maybe being an example of that.
So these are things that net mode
is something that we kind of often need to query
about what our current context is
and therefore what our responsibility is
for kind of sending information.
Obviously, if we are the client,
that's the time where we might need to be calling
server functions to send information to the server
about our local updates.
If we are a server, either a dedicated server
or a listen server, then it's our kind of responsibility
to be sending information out to other connected clients.
If we're a listen server,
we also know that we are gonna maintain
a certain amount of local state
and that's where it becomes important
to kind of bear in mind things like
not necessarily trusting your replicated using functions
to get called because it's not actually
gonna get replicated because it's local.
So all of these things, you know,
these things all have various meanings
and permutations in different scenarios.
Next, we have net role
and this can easily be confused with net mode
but it's important to talk about,
it's actually, these are two quite distinct
and importantly distinct things.
So you can't, these two things are not interchangeable.
Net role is essentially to describe
who has authority over a given entity.
So the three situations that you can have
are role authority, role simulated proxy
or role autonomous proxy.
Authority lets us know essentially whether,
who basically controls the data about this actor, right?
So if we go for role authority,
this is typically gonna be the case
for most things on the server.
The server has authority over the vast majority
of the kind of game data
but in the situation of like,
we go to play an attack animation
and we hit against a wall, right?
Then we might spawn some visual effect actors,
we might spawn some sound effects.
It is not, the server doesn't need to know
about those things, right?
We are going to spawn those sound effects
and those visual effects locally to our player.
The server doesn't need to care about them
and therefore those actors are our responsibility.
We are full control over them.
We will have a unique copy of those things.
It literally doesn't matter if we're client A,
it doesn't matter if client B never knows about them,
it's kind of their responsibility
to spawn their own visuals and sound effects
if they need them
but we've just kind of done this locally.
In that situation, the remote client
would have the authority over those sound effects,
over those locally spawned,
over the sound effects or the visual effects.
You would also be the authority for any of your UI
because again, this is not being controlled by the server.
You as the local player, as a local connected client
are the authority over any changes
that are happening to that data
are something that you as the local computer
are in control of.
The other situation obviously is that we are the server
in which case we are the authority
for the vast majority of the data,
in which case it's our responsibility
to replicate data to other things.
If we are in control of that data,
we need to send that data out
to all the kind of simulated entities.
Again, obviously authority, when we are a listen server,
we have authority over both of those things.
We have authority over our local UI,
over our locally spawned visual effects and sound effects.
And we also have authority over the positions
of all the enemies because we are also the server.
So again, that's why these two things
don't necessarily line up
because they are different in different scenarios.
Simulated proxy is when an actor
is kind of spawned on the server
and replicated down to the local client,
but it is owned by another client.
So this is gonna be something like
the enemy players in your game,
they are gonna be simulated proxy.
So all you're receiving
is a simulated representation of that thing.
The server is controlling it.
The server might be getting information about it
from a different client,
but ultimately all you need to know
is this is being controlled from elsewhere.
You do not have control over it.
You do not have responsibility for it.
You're just getting all this information
essentially from the server.
And then last of all, we have autonomous proxy.
Autonomous proxy is when it's spawned on the server,
but it's kind of the local machine
that is kind of has a degree of control over it.
So this is gonna be your local player controller,
your pawn.
These are gonna be autonomous proxies.
So it's the server that actually has control over the data
but you have a degree of responsibility
for kind of making changes about it
and sending those things to the server to say,
hey server, you know, I've updated my position.
And so, you know, please be notified of that.
The server may make corrections and things like that,
but yeah, autonomous proxy is going to describe
your role as a player
for the things that you are kind of player controlling.